[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Gil Siméoni bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous président du conseil
exécutif de Corse on va longuement
parler avec vous évidemment de la
question de l'autonomie de la Corse mais
d'abord un mot sur l'actualité est ce
qui se passe en Israël on découvre jour
après jour l'ampleur des crimes l'armée
israélienne ce matin par parle de plus
de 1200 morts après les attaques du
Hamas comment vous qualifiez ce qui est
en train de se passer je crois que
malheureusement ce sont des actes d'une
barbarie précisément inqualifiable donc
bien sûr beaucoup d'émotions de la
solidarité l'espoir aussi que le sort
des des otages puisse être réglé
favorablement malheureusement aussi la
crainte d'une escalade militaire au
Proche Orient et peut-être au-delà et
puis le temps de l'émotion qui continue
le temps de la guerre qui
malheureusement risque de s'ouvrir il
faudrait aussi le plus rapidement
possible construire des perspectives
dans un premier temps de de
normalisation et dans un deuxième temps
de paix parce que au-delà des des crimes
qui ont été perpétrés par les siqueres
du
Hamas je crois que le le problème de
fond c'est que depuis 1993 et les
accords d'Oslo la la logique de paix
c'est embourbée en Israël et en
Palestine mais il est possible de
reprendre les négociations paix dans le
dans le contexte actuel et avec ce qui
vient de se passer certainement pas tout
de suite mais je pense que la communauté
internationale doit peser aussi dans ce
sens-là on sait bien qu'en arrière-plan
il y a d'un côté le fanatisme euh
l'islamisme radical quelquefois le jeu
trouble de certaines puissances
régionales notamment l'Iran le Qatar
peut-être même en arrière-plan la Russie
dans le contexte international que tout
le monde connaît euh mais au-delà de ça
le le véritable problème aussi c'est
c'est à mon avis la politique suicidaire
qui a été menée depuis de trop
nombreuses années par le gouvernement de
Monsieur netanahou et la politique
notamment de colonisation active dans
les territoires de sjordanie qui ne peut
conduire qu'à l'impasse donc je je crois
que c'est aussi un problème interne à la
société israélienne et que il faut faire
réémerger des forces politiques et des
acteurs qui pensent la paix plutôt que
systématiquement enemancer la guerre
aujourd'hui il y a une unanimité dans la
classe politique quasi unanimité puisque
la France insoumise elle refuse de
qualifier le Hamas d'organisation
terroriste est-ce que vous comprenez
cette position est-ce que pour vous
c'est une organisation terroriste je
crois que la plupart des organisations
internationales qualifient le Hamas
aujourd'hui d'organisation terroristes
les crimes qui ont été commis notamment
les atrocités contre contre des civils
contre des familles entières contre des
bébés sont des des gestes inqualifiables
au-delà de la qualification de de
terroristes ceux qui il faut je le
répète à mon avis c'est essayer de
stopper l'escalade guerrière et de
construire une perspective de paix on va
parler de l'autonomie de laaccmanuel
Macron était en course il y a 2 semaines
il a engagé l'accord sur le chemin de
l'autonomie mais maintenant ce sont les
parlementaires qui ont la main et
notamment le Sénat vous avez rencontré
hier le président du Sénat Gérard Larché
est-ce qu'il est prêt à voter cette
autonomie de la Corse je pense pas que
nous ayons abordé cette question en tout
cas dans ces terme d'abord c'est une
visite nécessaire de courtoisie j'ai
félicité le le président Larcher pour sa
réélection et puis on sait
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui la la
discussion de l'autonomie doit à notre
sens déboucher je l'espère favorablement
et si elle débouche ça passera par une
révision constitutionnelle donc qui dit
révision constitutionnelle dit
normalement majorité des 3/5e au Congrès
donc dans cette perspective làà le Sénat
euh est bien sûr un acteur et un
partenaire incontournable donc c'était
une prise de contact avec le président
Larcher pour lui expliquer c'était que
du contact non bien sûr on a parlé aussi
de des perspectives qui étaient ouvertes
d'abord je lui ai euh j'ai eu l'
occasion de le voir déjà en 2018 au
moment de la première révision
constitutionnelle envisagée qui a été
suspendue puis abandonné dans les
conditions que l'on connaît euh c'était
aussi l'occasion de le revoir de lui
expliquer comment les choses avaient
évolué en cor au plan politique depuis
2018 et puis lui présenter la
délibération à autonomie autonomie qui a
été votée à une très large majorité le 5
juillet dernier par l'Assemblée de Corse
une majorité de 46 voix sur 63 donc près
de 75 % de l'Assemblée je crois qu'il
est important aussi au-delà des
discussions juridiques
constitutionnelles que le Sénat qui est
une assemblée politique prennent aussi
l'exacte mesure de la situation
politique actuelle en course ce qui veut
dire ce qui veut dire qu'il y a une
aspiration très forte largement
majoritaire à un statut d'autonomie à à
une sortie de logique de conflit qui a
structuré les relations entre la Corse
et l'État depuis plus de d'un demi-sècle
et que avant même que de parler des
formes juridiques et constitutionnelles
de ce statut d'autonomie il faut
comprendre que cette aspiration à la
démocratie qui s'est notamment exprimé
dans les urnes à trois reprises et
chaque fois avec plus de force en 2015
2017 et 2021 cette aspiration à la
démocratie doit être entendu et prise en
compte par la classe politique française
par le gouvernement et par l'État mais
la question maintenant c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on met derrière ce mot d'autonomie on
imagine que vous avez parlé de ça hier
avec Gérard Larcher est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord sur ce que vous mettez derrière
le mot alors ça justement le je dirais
l'objet du travail à venir dans la
période de de 6 mois qui est la deuxème
phase du processus qui a été initié vous
en rappelez en mars 2022 au lendemain de
de l'assassinat d'Ivan colonne et des
manifestations violentes de l'émotion
considérable que cet assassinat en
milieu carcéral dans des conditions
troubles à suscité il y avait mais ça a
été en fait cet assassinat a été en
quelque sorte le l'étincelle qui a mis
le feu à la prairie parce qu'il y avait
un sentiment de à la fois de colère
d'inquiétude en cors généralisé
notamment du fait que ce que les Corses
avaient demandé à travers les urnes à
plusieurs reprises n'était pratiquement
pas entendu et et beaucoup d'entre nous
considéraent à mon avis à juste raison
qu'il y avait même une forme de de
mépris démocratique qui n'était pas qui
n'était pas acceptable aujourd'hui on
est dans une autre logique on a
travaillé pendant 18 mois une délégation
d'élut de la Corse le ministre
dararmanin qui avait été mandaté à cette
fin par le président Emmanuel Macron
jusqu'à la visite de la semaine dernière
d'Emmanuel Macron présent la République
et un discours important devant
l'Assemblée de Corse pour dire que la
perspective de l'autonomie était
aujourd'hui clairement ouverte
maintenant effectivement il faut donner
un contenu à ce statut d'autonomie et
puis au-delà de des institutions il y a
un enjeu économique social culturel
sociétal c'est ce à quoi nous devons
travailler nous allons continuer d'y
travailler au sein de la société corse
avec l'ensemble des forces politiques et
l'ensemble des forces vives et il faut
aussi convaincre et notamment convaincre
les les parlementaires députés sénateurs
emuel Macron dans son discours il n'a
prononcé ni le mot de peuple corse ni le
mot de coofficialité de la langue ni le
mot de statut de résident qui sont vos
trois demandes est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'on va vers une autonomie de façade
alors bien évidemment je ne peux pas
imaginer qu'on aille vers une autonomie
de façade j'ai noté comme les
observateurs que des mots et des
marqueurs politiques
importants faisaient défaut dans le
discours du président mais j'ai relevé
aussi que le Président de la République
a indiqué qu'il n'y avait aucune ligne
rouge et qu'il fallait aborder les
problématiques de la lang Corse euh de
la lutte contre la spéculation
immobilière ou de la reconnaissance
notamment politique et symbolique
éventuellement juridique du peuple corse
en se tenant à distance et des totems et
des tabous donc c'est de ça que nous
allons parler mais pas que de ça euh ce
sont les points sans doute les plus
irritants les plus difficiles à traiter
mais ce n'est pas parce qu'ils sont
difficiles à trait à traiter qu'ils sont
intraitables et c'est aussi ce que j'ai
essayé de ça veut dire que ça peut
encore être derrière le mot d'autonomie
je pense parce que l'autonomie d'abord
c'est au partout dans le monde et
notamment pour toutes les grandes îles
de la Méditerranée c'est un pouvoir
législatif reconnu à la collectivité
autonome alors on sait que c'est une
notion qui est une notion nouvelle dans
le droit constitutionnel français
notamment pour un territoire qui n'est
pas un territoire ultramarin mais cette
notion d'autonomie est corrélée pour
nous à la singularité de la Corse qui
est une grande île de Méditerranée qui a
une histoire constitutionnelle
importante avec la course au 18e siècle
faisait un peu l'admiration du siècle
des Lumières et qu'elle a été à
l'origine de la la constitution écrite
la première constitution écrite et puis
aussi une légitimité démocratique il y a
un combat historique qui a été porté
depuis 50 ans en faveur de l'autonomie
et aujourd'hui il y a un vote très
majoritaire à travers les législatif
parce que ça effectivement c'est un
point important vous souhaitez qu'il
aille jusqu'ù ben je pense c'est ce dont
nous avons à discuter puisque par
exemple le souci qui a été exprimé par
le Président de la République à travers
son discours et qui a été réaffirmé hier
par le présid président du Sénat c'est
bien sûr que cette autonomie et ce
pouvoir législatif soit si demain il il
devait être connu ce que j'espère et ce
pourquoi nous allons nous battre soit
encadrer le contrôle par exemple du
Conseil constitutionnel une forme de
contrôle c'est ce que j'ai proposé et un
droit de saisi sur l'exercice du
contrôle de constitutionnalité
éventuellement par l'opposition au sein
de l'Assemblée de Corse par le
représentants de l'État peut-être même
par les présidents du Parlement de du ou
de l'Assemblée nationale tout ça est à à
discuter mais ce qu'il faut mais dans
quel champ alors dans un champ la
délibération qui a été votée par
l'Assemblée de Corse est une
délibération qui met en perspective une
autonomie de plein droit et de plein
exercice celle que nous avons défendu
devant les électeurs et électrices et
qui a été validée par le suffrage
universel c'est-à-dire une construction
qui existe ailleurs pas en France pour
l'instant mais ailleurs je pense par
exemple au statut des des assorts dans
l'état portugais qui est un État
unitaire avec d'un côté les compétences
régaliennes qui sont exercé par l'État
et et de l'autre les les compétences qui
sont exercées par la collectivité
autonome ça c'est l'objectif que nous
poursuivons mais il est évident que cela
doit se faire de façon progressive donc
ce qui est envisageable mais là encore
ça sera l'objet des discussions aussi
bien au sein des forces politiques
corseque dans la la discussion avec la
représentation parlementaire le
gouvernement c'est de d'identifier un
certain nombre de secteurs qui sont des
secteurs pour nous essentiels je pense
par exemple à la lutte contre la
spéculation euh la question du
patrimoine foncier la question du
développement économique la fiscalité
dans certains cas dans lequel cette
compétence législative aurait vocation à
s'exprimer on a également parlé d'un
pouvoir d'adaptation dans d'autres
domaines qui serait un pouvoir
d'adaptation direct et qui ne serait
plus un pouvoir législatif mais un
pouvoir réglementaire je pense qu'il
faut que nous construisions autour de
cela mais et la su Gérard marché est
prêt à vous suivre nous n'en sommes pas
là et le le président du Sénat hier ne
m'a pas dit ce que seraient ses
intentions et ce d'autant mieux que pour
l'instant
la discussion et notamment avec le Sénat
n'a pas été engagée sur le fond
technique j' il vous a fixé aucune ligne
rouge j'espère pouvoir pouvoir être reçu
prochainement par le président de la
commission des Lois du Sénat lui
présenter la délibération voter le 5
juillet dernier par l'Assemblée de Corse
et puis engager une discussion qui est
une discussion à la fois politique bien
sûr mais également juridique technique
fiscale budgétaire et donc Infiné
constitutionnelle mais Gérard Larché n'a
mis aucune ligne rouge en tout cas N
nous n'étions pas les un ni les uns ni
les autres dans un esprit de ligne rouge
la volonté me semble-til est claire et
partagée c'est trouver un chemin on sait
que ce n'est pas facile ce que j'ai dit
également au président du Sénat mais je
l'avais dit au président de la
République c'est que à mon avis il faut
aborder aujourd'hui la recherche d'une
solution à travers la prise en compte
aussi de ce qui se joue en course ce qui
se joue en course c'est sortir
définitivement la logique de conflit
engager la Corse à la fois dans la paix
et enraciner cette paix qui est un bien
précieux mais le meilleur moyen de de
garantir la logique d'apaisement c'est
également d'ofrir une perspective
politique et pour construire la
perspective politique on est dans une
démocratie le premier élément à prendre
en compte c'est le vote et le vote des
cors il a été clair à plusieurs reprises
notamment en faveur d'un statut
d'autonomie on les connaît un peu les
lignons rouges de Gérard Larché quand
même il a donné une interview au Figaro
notamment la semaine dernière où il dit
la différenciation oui l'unité de la
République n'est mais l'unité de la
République n'est pas négociable la
coofficialité c'est non il n'y a qu'un
peuple français est-ce que ça part mal
ça part mal lorsqu'on présente les
choses de façon abrupte et et ça peut
être le cas notamment dans un article de
presse où on peut pas forcément c'est
pas exactement aborder la nuance les
choses dans leurs nuances et il est
normal aussi que dans un début de
discussion chaque parti réaffirme avec
fermeté et
conviction sa position et sa façon de
voir les choses moi ce que j'ai dit hier
à Gérard marché concernant le peuple
corse le peuple corse c'est une évidence
c'est une évidence historique c'est une
évidence culturelle c'est une évidence
linguistique et c'est une évidence
politique maintenant sa reconnaissance
constitutionnelle pose des problèmes qui
sont des problèmes considérables parce
que la Constitution française au jour
d'aujourd'hui ne reconnaît qu'un seul
peuple c'est le peuple français donc à
nous de trouver un chemin d'abord
politique et ensuite juridique pour que
cette aspiration à la reconnaissance du
peuple corse puisse être prise en compte
par la République de la même façon il
est normal que le président du Sénat
réaffirme son attachement au principe
d'unité de la République l'autonomie y
compris l'autonomie de plein droit et de
plein exercice est également une
appartenance à la République française
donc je pense que là aussi on doit
trouir on doit pouvoir trouver un chemin
en tout cas c'est c'est ma volonté et
c'est mon objectif d'autant qu'à peine
le discours d'Emmanuel Macron devant
l'Assemblée de Corse finie votre
collègue leï chîn Gérard qui préside la
région Bretagne a demandé la même chose
pour sa région est-ce que c'est la
preuve que ça peut être le début de la
fin de l'unité de la République et et
que ça ça fait le jeu de ceux qui disent
mais l'autonomie de l'accord c'est une
remise en cause de l'unité de la
République bon notre objectif n'est pas
de de dynamiter la République ni de
remettre en cause ces valeurs et
principes auxquels d'ailleurs nous
sommes attachés parce que au-delà des
valeurs et principes de la République
sont des valeurs et principes universels
qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs y compris dans
dans la constitution de Pascal Paul au
18e siècle non moi ce que j'ai dit au
président là ça risque de faire boule de
neige al ça peut faire boule de neige
sauf que nous demandons notamment dans
la délibération qu'il y ait un titre
dans la Constitution consacrée à la
Corse pourquoi parce que c'est
précisément une façon constitutionnelle
d'encadrer le statut de la Corse et de
consacrer sa singularité la Corse n'est
pas une région de droit commun y compris
une région de droit commun à forte
spécificité la Corse n'est pas non plus
la Polynésie ou la Nouvelle-Calédonie
donc un titre et des articles
spécifiques consacrés à la Corse une
façon de dire il y a une singularité
Corse euh une île une île de
Méditerranée une situation politique
qu'on retrouve pas ailleurs une histoire
constitutionnelle qu'on ne retrouve pas
ailleurs et des aspirations et des
éventuellement des problèmes à traiter
et à solutionner qu'on ne retrouve pas
ailleurs et on le fait à travers d'
statut d'autonomie sou généris
c'està-dire adapté à la réalité de la
course en s'inspirant de ce qui se fait
ailleurs et làardch a dit oui non il a
pas dit oui il a écouté ce que j'avais à
lui dire ce que je dis aussi c'est que
si demain d'autres régions en France
aspirent à la prise en compte plus fort
de la spécifique de leur spécificité ça
peut très bien se traiter dans le cas
d'une réforme de décentralisation
avancée mais la décentralisation avancée
d'un point de vue de la nature juridique
ce n'est pas l'autonomie que nous
souhaitons pour la Corse donc chacun son
chacun sa réforme après ce sont les
peuples aussi et les électrices et les
électeurs et leurs élus qui s'expriment
moi ce que je sais c'est qu'encore s'il
y a 70 % des électeurs avec un taux de
participation aux élections très
largement supérieure à la moyenne
nationale 70 % des électrices élector de
Corse qui se sont prononcés en faveur
d'un statut d'autonomie tel que je viens
de vous l'exposer je pense que cette
aspiration légitime historique
démocratiquement exprimé doit être prise
en compte et écouté et vous l'avez dit
pour que ce soit validé il faut que 3/5e
du Parlement vote cette révision
constitutionnel est-ce que dans le
contexte politique actuel Emmanuel
Macron vous a fait une promesse
intenable d'abord Emmanuel Macron ne
nous a pas fait de promesse Emmanuel
Macron il a promis d'engager l'ACC sur
la il a dit qu'il était prêt à s'engager
qu'il s'engagerait personnellement pour
soutenir euh un statut d'autonomie il a
dit employé le terme d'autonomie à la
Corse moi je pe pas vous l'avez compris
comment d'ailleurs écoutez je pense que
ce qu'il a voulu dire c'est que le
statut d'autonomie de la cor doit être
un statut soui généris qui a vocation et
c'est ce que nous avons fait pendant la
première phase des travaux à se nourrir
et à s'inspirer de ce qui marche
ailleurs et vous savez le le le
l'Assemblée de Corse sous la présidence
de de marie-anttoinette mopertui euh à
audition né très largement y compris des
îles de M des élus ou des fonctionnaires
d'îles de Méditerranée de Région
autonome et ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
l'autonomie ça marche et ça marche
ailleurs ça crée du développement
économique ça crée de la justice sociale
ça permet la reconnaissance de de d'une
identité culturelle ou linguistique et
c'est pas une logique ni de
confrontation ni de rupture donc c'est
ce qu'on va essay mais dans sa révision
constitutionnel Emmanuel Macron il a pas
mis que la Corse il y a aussi la
question deivg il y a aussi la question
du référendum est-ce que du coup vous
créz que l'accord soit la victime
collatérale bah c'est certain que nous
n'avons pas envie d'être aspiré dans
dans un débat qui serait autre que celui
concernant l'évolution institutionnelle
la solution politique à construire pour
l'accord c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai écouté bien sûr ce que propose
comme chemin le président de la
République mais il est évident que si
demain nous avons la possibilité d'avoir
une révision constitutionnelle qui soit
consacrée uniquement à la Corse pour que
l'ensemble des parlementaires à travers
leurs votes et sans considération autres
et notamment tiré de la vie politique
national à répondre à l'aspiration des
Corses à l'autonomie à travers une seule
et unique question donc un texte à part
et le reste dans un A TEX je pense c'est
une piste qui est envisageable et qui
est peut-être préférable pour que cette
questionl ne ne soit pas c'est
envisageable ou pour vous c'est la seule
possible est-ce que vous demandez à
Emmanuel Macron un texte à part encore
une fois on peut pas arriver dans une
discussion qui est complexe en disant
moi ma solution c'est celle-là et c'est
la seule possible il y a un certain
nombre de possibilités et d'options qui
sont sur la table parmi ces option il y
a celle d'avoir un vote et une révision
constitutionnelle consacré à la
situation politique de la course à son
évolution institutionnelle et à la
construction d'une solution notamment
une solution d'autonomie si on peut
poser cette questionl et cette questionl
seulement je pense que c'est une façon
de circonscrire de façon intéressante le
débat vous le disiez tout à l'heure Gill
Simon il y a une délibération de
l'assemblée Corse à une large majorité
mais pas à l'unanimité or Emmanuel
Macron quand il est venu il vous a dit
qu'il conditionnait cette nouvelle étape
institutionnelle à un accord unanime des
élus de lîle est-ce que vous pensez
l'obtenir alors j'ai c'est pas parce
qu'on a trouvé un certain nombre de
points d'accord avec le président de la
République qu'on est d'accord sur tout
ce que je lui ai dit c'est que
l'unanimité n'existe nulle part et à la
limite est-elle souhaitable et dans quel
pays ou dans quelle région a-t-on
subordonné la recherche et la mise en
œuvre d'un accord politique une
unanimité nulle part ça n'existe pas et
si j'étais un peu malicieux j'aurais pu
également indiquer au au président de la
République que le vote de l'Assemblée de
Corse a recueilli 75 % des suffrages des
élus et que aucun texte qui a été voté
par les gouvernements successifs euh qui
se sont qui se sont qui qui qui on qui
ont été en situation aucun des textes
n'a été voté et c'est une majorité
aujourd'hui qui qui qui qui fait voter y
compris des textes importants avec sans
majorité à travers le 493 donc on a déjà
une majorité très large maintenant cette
majorité vous dites cette condition n'a
pas lieu d'être cette condition en tout
cas à mon avis ne peut pas être rempli
et ne peut même pas être demandé par
contre ce que j'entends aussi c'est que
les points d'équilibre sont à rechercher
pour que chaque
parti avec un
eu en Corse et à Paris puisse considérer
que dans l'accord politique finale à
rechercher à construire l'essentiel ou
ce qu'elle considè essentiel est
préservé on peut pas être dans une
logique il faut à la fois une logique où
on écoute et prend en compte le fait
majoritaire que nous représentons
aujourd'hui et le fait majoritaire que
nous représentons doit aussi faire un
certain nombre d'efforts pour permettre
une adhésion encore plus large et
notamment de convaincre les
parlementaires mais il faut pas inverser
la problématique et demander aux faits
majoritaires de renoncer à ce qui est
essentiel et notamment de renoncer à ce
qui a été validé par les urnes et ce qui
a été aussi au cœur d'un combat
démocratique qui est mené depuis plus
d'un dem est-ce que pour vous il faut un
référendum sur ce qui qui sortira de vos
discussions avec les parlementaires ou
est-ce que les élections territoriales
ont fait office de consultation les
élections territoriales à trois reprises
ont fait office de très larges
consultations ceci étant nous sommes des
démocrates et je pense et je le redis
aussi compris dans le contexte actuel je
pense qu'il y a pas d'autres chemins
pour la Corse pour toutes les sociétés
mais je parle ici de la Corse peut pas y
avoir d'autres chemin que la démocratie
à la fois comme méthode et comme
objectif et dans cette perspective là il
est bien évident que dès lors que l'on
envisage une réforme importante un
statut d'autonomie une révision
constitutionnelle cela justifie légitime
et même commande de consulter le peuple
vous nous l'avez dit à plusieurs
reprises pendant cette interview Gill
Simon de cette question de l'autonomie
va dépendre la sortie du cycle de
violence et la paix durable encore s'il
y a une nouvelle nuit bleu dans la nuit
de dimanche à lundi une vingtaine de
bâtiments qui ont été touchés
principalement des résidences
secondaires le flncr revendiquit ces
actions est-ce que vous les condamnez
vous bah écoutez moi je suis en
désaccord avec la violence politique et
j'ai plaidé depuis que je suis rentrer
de façon significative en politique
d'abord comme simple militant ensuite
comme élu d'opposition et désormais
comme président du conseil exécutif j'ai
plaidé au sein de l'ensemble de la
famille nationaliste qui inclut bien sûr
les indépendantistes pour que la page de
la violence clandestine soit
définitivement tourné donc sur ce
principe- là qui est pour moi un
principe intangible je ne varie pas et
je dirais même que nous sommes àforurie
aujourd'hui encore plus qu'hier dans une
situation qui commande et impose de se
détour de la violence clandestine il
peut pas y avoir d'avenir heureux dans
le fracas des bombes dans les jeunes ou
moins jeunes em prisonné dans les
familles qui pleurent l'avenir de la cor
ça doit être un avenir de développement
économique de
sérénité un avenir qui nous permet aussi
de nous affranchir des menaces de la
spéculation immobilière des dérives
mafieusesise des actions du fllnc ça
peut freiner voir bloquer ce processus
d'autonomie je pense et j'espère que non
au contraire je dirais que la tentation
du retour à la violence doit jouer comme
un aiguillon puissant pour dire il y a
un autre chemin l'autre chemin c'est
écouter ce qu'on dit les Corses à
travers les urnes et c'est construire
une solution politique qui permet à
chaque parti de considérer que
l'essentiel est préservé une dernière
question est-ce que de la réussite de ce
processus d'autonomie Gill Siméon dépend
aussi la suite pour vous est-ce que vous
représenterez au territorial sil
échoue chaque chaque jour suffit sa
peine moi aujourd'hui je suis engagé
pleinement dans ma fonction de président
de de conseil exécutif de Corse ça veut
dire d'abord gérer au quotidien les
affaires de la Corse dans tous les
domaines y compris le domaines
économique social les infrastructures
parce que à côté de la discussion sur
l'autonomie il a aussi une discussion
par exemple sur le service public aérien
par exemple sur le développement des
infrastructures par exemple sur le
soutien à l'enseignement à la formation
la lutte contre la précarité donc ça
c'est mon quotidien à côté de ça il y a
un combat politique qui est mené par des
et qui a été mené par des générations de
femmes et d'hommes et je m'inscris aussi
dans ce siège là l'objectif aujourd'hui
est apporté demain un statut d'autonomie
nous l'attendons depuis 50 ans faut pas
laisser passer le train de l'histoire il
faut monter dans le train de l'histoire
et puis après il faut aller sereinement
vers d'autres lendemain on verra ce qu'
seront pour ce qui me concerneevendrez
nous en parler mais c'est pas le plus
important l'important c'est l'avenir de
la merci merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité on passe au club des
territoires